[Music]
all right so it's marshall mr wonderful
josh and ben now we're all here to talk
about multiple things but mostly about
investing
now you guys have a new fund we do let's
talk about that what is the purpose of
the fund
sure and i i thought that the purpose of
our of our talk today was just to talk
about how great denim shirts are and how
good i look at that
i think i look spectacular with this i
think you did but i mean we coordinated
it we we got the text messages going
this morning so
uh in all in all seriousness so we
started animal capital back in march and
and so the fund is called animal capital
yeah okay
uh and is there a reason sometimes the
name says a lot about the mission uh it
might be a better question for joshua
josh you can tell me if i'm misspeaking
here of course i think it's really the
the idea of an animal just aligned with
our hustle that there's nothing that we
will not do to find a way to work harder
and to work smarter yeah and then they
get the animal they're hunting for those
investments right it's like it's like
the investments are our prey and we're
the predators so no matter what's gonna
happen we're gonna be the animal that
finds out it's exactly right whether
we're hunting for lp's in our fund or
hunting for things to invest in or
hunting for ways to drive value for our
founders like that's i think we have to
admit i see a lot of fun names i talked
to a lot of fund managers i've never
heard of animal capital it's a great
name thank you
just out of interest
animal capital.com we own animalcap.com
and we own the name animal capital
period that's very important we really
started this fund um
out of interest in people aligning with
our investment strategy
josh was nice enough to want to work
with me uh about a year ago a little bit
more than that now uh people are
offering josh and some of you know his
housemates and michael grew and our
other business partner equity and these
young businesses where they really well
you know that fits because michael is an
animal i know michael that's a fact see
there's there's multiple reasons right
it's not just one it was called animal
for like
now i really get it yeah but if it was
just michael it'd be called predator
capital
um
but we
uh you know they were getting offered
equity in all sorts of things like
so i mean really what's going on here is
josh is such a huge player in the
influencer space every guy in his dog is
coming after you to get an endorsement
right yeah so if you're going to endorse
something why don't you open it exactly
that's what that was our strategy it
really became we want to own everything
we touch we want a piece of everything
we're involved in and then when we were
going to start investing we realized the
value of ourselves in the advisory shows
as well and then we were bringing people
like marshall to really help us out on
that side and that kind of became our
game plan when we were going in and
investing in these companies is being
able to be everyone's best friend being
able to provide so much value and really
getting to also have the advisory side
as well to help out let's talk about the
criteria yeah because that's really what
matters you look at it through the same
filter every time right of course okay
so hit me
so you say the same filter every time i
would say the the initial things are you
know
our general scope and i i said john said
this to every investor in every master
investor coaches if it's not making
people's lives better or more fun we're
probably not investing in it i know that
seems almost like flippant or silly but
it narrows the scope for us to things
that we really believe are making
people's lives better so we think about
fintech life sciences a little bit of
consumer primarily better for you about
foods um
better certainly better food foods
that's the space that we've not only
gathered and we're significantly
invested in and uh hope to get some of
our founders under shark tank at some
point and founding ourselves
so that's that's one of your products
right yeah yeah so this was the
essentially more lifestyle type drink
compared to an energy drink the healthy
version of an energy drink so less
calories less sugar
what it's actually the caffeine is used
with it's used with green coffee or
green tea beans instead of going into uh
actually a lot more like the chemical
side of things so yeah it's just a
healthier variant of an energy drink
now why we're all sitting here together
is because we have done this together
unfortunately and so which is great it's
called wonderful and i have been
fascinated with
you know decentralized finance now for
three years because i'm using it now
you know to do all kinds of sort of
different things but i've realized that
it's really complicated and hard to do
i've had to hire three different people
inside my firm now that just deal with
all this stuff and i want to simplify it
and we've got the ceo of wonderful right
here
let's talk about this so ben what's
wonderful
wonderful is
really just focused on making d5 simple
like really simple for people it's first
of all what is d5 because most people
have no idea what it is d5 is probably
the most important sector to pay
attention to right now that's obviously
i'm biased but huge growth potential is
kind of a subset of crypto which is
giving people the power to own and
control their own assets so it's a you
know a huge so instead of sticking your
stuff in in the wallet like coinbase
you you put it in a decentralized
scenario a platform like wonderful yeah
exactly and you retain control over it
uh you know you're not giving up control
to you know somebody that uh could do
something fraudulent with it or or
something like that so it's it's a bit
there's a big movement behind this um
but we're like we're really only in the
very early innings of d5 so we're uh
with one or five we're really trying to
bring this to the masses now why i like
it and why i got involved is very simple
you can stake your assets and make
interest in my case i'm using usdc as
stablecoin
lending it out and making between five
and six percent that is very cool
because you can't make that in bank
account right
and so that's what we're going to be
able to do on wonderful and simplify it
right yeah exactly and it's something
where there's again there's a ton of
potential but it's only people that have
like you know 24 hours a day to spend
learning crypto and d5 that are able to
access it right now so the whole mission
is is you know democratizing finance but
you can only the only people that can
access it are like you know engineers
that are like you know in their
basements like dealing with this stuff
like 24 hours a day so i think uh
there's a there's a really important you
know goal here that we have which is
just making it accessible and uh for us
getting you know getting
you know you guys involved has been a
key part of that because it's uh you
know
it's really important to get the message
out
so the investment thesis sure let me see
if you agree with me marshall
you know
of all the people in this room yeah i've
got millions of followers but nothing
like josh has particularly with gen z
and gen z is more hip to crypto than any
other generation 100 percent so
my thought was if we get together on
this we can i can do millennials and
baby boomers and josh can do gen z and
we'll have a massive amount of people we
can show this product to and tell them
about it tell the story of the company
is that the way you see it yeah i mean
exactly like that i think for me
that's why i was so cool to be able to
be a part of wonder five's that we all
have this aligned
this aligned i would say passion and
it's empowering the youth it's bringing
in all these different ages together to
really learn about a space that is so
important to know about right really be
able to teach people what they can do
with their money with financial literacy
coming in and investing and like you
said gen z is the most hip generation to
crypto they are talking about it every
day they're seeing it on their social
medias every day they are
sometimes putting money into coins that
they
aren't getting any information on
there's no one advising them they don't
have a financial advisor telling them
what to do so
this platform is so important i think to
not just me and
gen z but so many different ages to
really learn about what they can do with
d5 yeah because i would like to make
sure that and this is the one thing that
i made sure when i invested in uh you
know the company you know along with ben
and the team we need to be compliant we
need to get our tax forms out we got to
do stuff that doesn't get us in trouble
i don't want to be a crypto cowboy i
don't want to do something that gets me
you know the tax guy mad at me like i
want to pay my taxes if i make money i'm
cool with it and i'm fine with that but
most of these platforms do not report
but this does and that's what i think is
so important
uh ben i do have one question for you
because we we talked about this a lot
and josh i had the chance to talk about
this on a couple of different news
networks the concept of lending for
yield and why that's such a big deal you
just walk through the really like
yeah i mean five-year-old version of
what on earth it means selling for yield
yeah i mean it basically means putting
your assets somewhere and then
generating interest on them so you know
we're used to depositing money in your
bank account and right now if you do
that with you know bank of america or
you know scotia bank wherever you are
it's like you know 0.25 percent that
you're getting so it's just it's really
that's not beating inflation inflation
is
yeah so people feel like like for you
know i'm a millennial for millennials
they feel like they're they're losing
out they're getting left behind when
that's where they're putting their
assets and i think it's really
interesting like gen z definitely has a
different they look at money differently
kevin's generation looks at money
differently they have different
objectives um but really it all kind of
comes together with
you know lending for yield is is is
locking your asset in somewhere and then
you know generating a significant amount
of interest in it uh which really puts
it ahead of what you can do with a with
a for the bank
so
what has it felt like or how has the
platform changed since you introduced
kevin and josh and myself to your lives
and
you've given us your cell phone number
and access to you into you and your
house
yeah i don't know kevin doesn't sleep i
guess
no it's it's been great like i uh i
don't know if i've told you this story
but uh
one of the conditions that kevin had
coming in as an investment was that you
guys could co-invest yeah yeah so i
think you told me that story yeah yeah i
just thought it made a lot of sense like
it's a perfect i mean look for other
things to do together because you're
obviously you've got a mandate to invest
in it you've got to fund you've got to
find ideas i think it's really good
financial service is the biggest market
in the world but let's talk about what
did happen you took it public this
company trades on the neon yeah we took
it public and but just on on your
question like i think it's it's it what
it's done is it's kind of changed my
perspective on how different
demographics look at finance because
again josh has you know you guys have
such a good lens on on gen z and what
the what the needs and desires are and
issues and you know kevin's audience is
more kind of traditional investment
community and there's all these
it's it's super interesting because
again everybody has different access to
finance and what efa is trying to do is
lower the barriers to entry and just
level the playing field so you can't do
that by just
having one demographic that is
representing your company um so this has
just opened it up where we're like okay
we have boomers we have millennials we
have gen z we're working on getting um
you know more female representation
other underrepresented groups so it's it
that's really cool i think that's that's
like the driving force like the fire
behind kind of what we're doing so super
excited about that what really got me
was i was you know my daughter was
listening to a podcast i was doing with
one of the crypto uh guys the pomp he's
legendary yeah yeah
yeah
and i'm talking to pop about how
complicated it was just to set up my
first staking on usdc loaning my first
usdc out there it was like mind numbing
hard yeah i mean it was brutal and my
daughter heard it savannah she's in new
york and said dad i want to do the same
thing i want interest off my my cash in
my bank account how do i do this i said
i don't know how to do it i have to hire
guys
and the whole idea of wonderfuy is that
she's going to be able to download and
do it
and be compliant and everything else
that's you know making this
something democratizing and making it
something the consumer can use is the
whole mission i think we're going to
kill it
yeah nobody's doing it like you look at
what we have
versus all the defy apps uh right now
they're just catering towards again
people that are like so ingrained in the
space and it's just it's the early
adopter problem like you see with a lot
of different technology where uh it's
just
serving more and more to that early user
and it's it's getting further further
away from something that like your
daughter can just pick up and understand
that's not adapting to try to obtain new
users no it's not it's just serving that
like there's more to that existing fan
base exactly exactly
i know it sounds silly but it really
feels to me the same way that now you
see like
two-year-olds at the dinner table with
the ipad and they know what they're
doing and you see them swiping or like
pausing a video and like i mean even
josh and i didn't know how to do that at
the time at the dinner table it's the
exact same thing with this when you
think about your savings account you
think about the way that you're gonna
make money and save for the future we're
just trying to teach people that level
of
like in the background bring when i
trained here i'm going to college
this is what i'm going to do i'm heading
my wonderful account and this is going
to be the way that i begin to build that
you know real base for the rest of my
life she'll just be like a second nature
like it's just you know
so i think with josh and i our job is to
get people to try it honey that's it
just
try it that's the key so if you're
listening to this and you haven't
downloaded wonderful yet do it what are
you
come on
exactly try it i mean learn something
it's real easy and start making interest
on your money which is really i think
kind of paramount to long-term investing
where you want to go with your career
josh why are you an investor anyways you
were just a dude on tick tock i think
for investing why was so cool to me was
just being a part of the future like
having that
that responsibility and and really that
power at the same time to know like i'm
gonna be involved in decisions at the
next amazon and at the next uber and be
a part of this this business world for a
really really long time you're taking
care of your own future because one day
you will be 65. and you've got to have
something in the bank
i know i gotta i gotta make sure i'm
able to feed my family and buy my mama
house when she retires and make sure my
my younger siblings are set for life
like that's
that's setting fi with uh investing
that's gonna be able to set myself up
for exponentially like just growing well
you can't do it unless you invest that's
the key you gotta learn how to do it and
the way you guys are doing this for the
fund like from a founder's perspective
is amazing
because you just get more bought in like
that you were talking about the equity
versus kind of like the other pay
promotion stuff and it's way different
when you're a founder like i've worked
with paid promoters before and it's much
it's much more like you know one and
done uh and you don't have the buy-in on
like the long-term mission and objective
so it's not authentic it's not yeah
exactly it's like isn't it you're
representing like you're representing
this and so i mean you guys obviously
get that that's why you structured like
you know your fund like like that but
it's uh it's it's really great from like
a company's perspective
it's even it's honestly even a step
further because i've talked i've talked
to a lot of venture businesses that have
they've won it's a random founder in
chicago and they've got one friend who's
got a friend that has two million
followers on you your subscribers on
youtube or on tick tock or whatever and
they want to just offer them something
for free the fact that founders see us
and they say this is a thoughtful
decision that they're making with some
of the most powerful people in the world
and i mean the founders of netflix and
android and tinder are investors in our
business um
that plus everything else that we do to
sort of like affect the outcome for you
um well it says long term it's exactly
right yeah it's it's not just churn and
burn exactly
i mean that's i think people are
starting to smell bs with this
influencer just
paying for them right
well there's a way to do it there's a
way to do it right i think that
the creators often time
know what their audience likes and what
they don't like right and then you're
going to see the creators that are going
to go and sell out for the deals and
then you're going to see some that don't
but the people that don't they're going
to ones that are going to achieve that
long-term wealth or the people that do
sell it for the brand deal you might
have a couple dollars on your bank
account for a while but unless you're
going investing that money and using
that you're going to end up drying out
yeah i i really think it has to be
transparent you know i i do endorsement
deals but i have to be using the product
i got to eat my own cooking so i'm very
very selective i'm a spokesperson for
stuff like start engine which is equity
crowdfunding but i also became a
shareholder ftx same thing shareholder
and paid spokesperson with tom brady uh
you know i didn't know tom was in the
crypto but it turns out his wife is
giselle so that's how he did that deal
and it's real like you know i eat the
cooking i think that's my motto eat your
own cookie if you don't eat your cooking
people are gonna see right through it
yeah what for you kevin when you're
looking when someone's bringing you
an endorsement to what are there a
couple of like the first things in the
lenses that you said it has to have x y
and z for us you know for me
i'm in the same mode of you guys i need
sustainability i don't want to be part
of you know doing something that harms
the planet that's not where my head's at
i'm one of the first guys to graduate
environmental studies in waterloo years
ago
the first cohort because i'm into that
stuff because i believe
customers of products that know you have
a mission become loyal because they want
to support the mission it's good for
business it's not just some bs
advertising
that's number one and i i also think i
can send a lot of products seem like you
guys do i recently got sent a beverage
i'm in the wine business so somebody
sent me something that wasn't wine and i
tried it it tasted like [ __ ] and i
thought i would so much i would never
ever endorse this crap if you like that
video wait did you see my next one don't
forget to click right over here and
subscribe